and there's everybody that do they call
you Kylie billionaire chatter well Ellen
yes they do she has this like entitled
it hey it's really not a bad title plus
it's fun to talk about and Kylie and her
momager Kris do just that on the season
premiere of The Ellen DeGeneres Show do
they really make fun of you did they
give you a hard time it's only when we I
don't know when we're like in a group
chat talking about like we should go on
a trip and that everyone's like Kylie
question mark you're gonna pay for it
right just stuff like that of course
this all goes back to Forbes calling
Kylie the world's youngest self-made
billionaire last year thanks to her
Kylie cosmetics Empire they just joke
with me just to stir so proud of me for
sure and do they but do they really do
they expect you to pay for all the stuff
no they don't really know just my stuff
my stuff yeah we saw some of that joking
during Kylie and Chloe's drunk make up
video money ain't everything has this
madness but it's not but it's not but it
but it's not okay coming from the
billionaire herself ah sisters but
really it's all in fun the fam is
actually super supportive and kind of
defensive of Kylie she made her own
money for over a decade she put it in
the bank
she saved every nickel and then when she
decided she really you know decided on
what she wanted to do she spent her
money on a venture that could have gone
south or north and it did really well so
think that takes away from the fact that
there was hard work put into something
I think that I think that you that
doesn't just happen if you're if you're
not doing something about it you're just
sitting at home being lazy I don't think
that could happen no yeah I think it
says something about just working I
don't care who you are how you know but
when you don't get it from someone else
that's self-made so it's not like that
was handed to her she figured that all
out I mean we all have okay back to the
Ellen interview Kylie also opened up
about babies stormy who's almost two
years old now she's so mellow
she takes more after you or Travis um
she is the perfect mixture of both of us
she's definitely like a little rager she
loves music but she's dancing in the
dressing room to all of you guys yeah
yeah you guys are all dancing she was
banging it's so cute it's cute but um
yeah she's the perfect picture of both
of us so a story's personality might be
a mix but her looks those are all Kylie
apparently too much like Kylie for
Grandma Kris she is like a little Kylie
it's really wild it's like sometimes she
looks at you and you think I have to
remind myself no that's my granddaughter
Kylie yeah you know for two seconds like
you can tease me loser huh yeah yeah ah
Kris Jenner never change
all right guys stick with ET for all
things Kylie Kris and the rest of the
kardashian-jenner z-- until next time
I'm Katie Krauss and bye for now
you